hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my fear The Walking Dead finale video
I feel like there was a big rally at the
end like they were just saving all the
best stuff so season 1 yeah
develop kind of slowly but I feel like
season 2 is gonna be a lot more exciting
I think the episode did an awesome job
about addressing some of the complaints
about the Travis character and just
actually start out by answering a couple
of season 2 questions and everyone kind
of wondered what's going on they've
already confirmed it like it got picked
up for season 2 a long time ago there's
gonna be 15 episodes they don't know
when it's gonna air exactly just
sometime in 2016 in the the airplane web
show like the the extra web show that
they've been posting they're gonna post
new episodes of that weekly during
Walking Dead Season 6 during commercial
breaks it's only gonna be like a minute
per episode so it's gonna be way smaller
than I thought it was gonna be but one
of those characters will be on fear The
Walking Dead Season 2 it's all about a
walker outbreak happening on an airplane
so cue all your snakes on a plane posts
but careful for spoilers from the fear
of The Walking Dead finale as we get
into it starting with top 5 WTF moments
a new round of the giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video number 5 Travis let's Ophelia's
boyfriend go because it's the right
thing to do it's the thing that good man
would do and Daniel has the line later
in the episode which kind of tags that
where he says see what doing the good
thing get to you
so by that measure if killing Liza at
the end was also the good thing see what
that gets up it'll be interesting to see
how that informs his character in season
2 like if that's gonna haunt him and
cause some more problems the takeaway is
that doing the good thing in this mad
world as strained calls it will get you
nowhere it's gonna expose you to
unforeseen consequences down the road
but if you've been watching the main
show you know that's not the whole story
you know just because you might not be
able to do the good thing doesn't mean
you can't do the right thing like at
least for a little while during season 5
Rick started doing the right thing in
being really cautious I mean the
question now is is is he going overboard
but just looking at the spectrum of
characters starting from you know really
good to kind of evil seeming you have
Travis the good man it went in you have
Daniel who's kind of in the middle like
he's not afraid to do the right thing
and at the other end you have strand who
seems that there might be something
going on with him that we don't know
about something bad speaking of which on
a number four strand is the new Shane
you aren't useful right now sorry gotta
go kill me well
you're already on your way you can keep
the watch he's protect full of Nick as
they're like they're slowly escaping but
that's only because he needs Nick he's
not doing it out of the kindness of his
heart or anything like that
screen right now is like one of the most
interesting characters he's gonna be
really awesome to watch in season two
let me know if he's your favorite new
character right now but on talking dead
on the after show Cliff Curtis said that
Travis doesn't trust him at all he's way
too confident just something nuts about
him something is totally off and he
would rather take Daniel any day over
strand Daniels a little bit more honest
about who he is he's a little bit more
realistic I mean what he says sounds
kind of dire like it's too late to help
these people but he's not malicious
about it in the way that strand is
speaking of Daniel onto number three
Daniel serves the military with the
super PAC from the stadium just just one
of the best casual Walker reveals ever
that reveal was probably the funniest
moment in the episode in an episode
that's not necessarily meant to be funny
I mean it's pretty gritty drama so you
don't find a lot of humor and things but
this was funny you might want to save
those bullets and he just he casually
walks away
I'll Austrian had the line too like
they've figured it out don't worry
they're slow but they opened fire in the
super pack and the camera pans up and
you see it's it's like the super PAC
from season four it just goes on and on
and on I think they said there were
about 2,000 of them in that stadium but
there might be more that have just added
on is they walk down the street Daniel
was pretty awesome in this episode he I
don't think he was the biggest MVP but
this was definitely his high point and
what do you think about the way that he
took it when Liza told him what happened
to his wife she didn't say I killed her
but she did tell him they were they were
dead Oh philias reaction felt pretty
authentic like of course they're gonna
be upset
Daniel kind of accepts that though I
think in the instant that Liza told him
what happened he kind of realized yeah I
mean it was really bad in seeing
everything that had happened everything
that was going on around them he was
able to connect the dots and sense that
there probably wasn't gonna be anything
they could do to help her and because
Liza died at the end I don't think that
Daniel is gonna be too pissed off at the
other characters about his wife's death
next season I think it's gonna haunt him
but I don't think that he's gonna take
it out on the rest of the group on the
number two okay Leah's boyfriend tries
to kill Daniel shoots Ophelia when she
tries to stop him and then Travis takes
him down
and just wails on him I don't think it
had quite the energy of Rick beating
Pete like the stakes hadn't risen that
high yet but it was kind of that he was
kind of invoking that energy that was
the breaking point the good man
Travis kind of died a little bit inside
the good Travis was total Walker Bates
so be glad that he died
I mean he's also a lot more fun now now
that he's kind of opened up Spanish on
in my number one WTF moment pretty
obvious here
Travis kills Liza and I like that she
didn't ask him verbally they just they
kind of shared that look and knew what
needed to happen
don't forget too that before he walked
up on her in Madison Madison was ready
to do it - I think it's evidence that
all those characters are strong like
even Chris who's kind of at the bottom
of the barrel in terms of strength stood
up for Alicia whenever those soldiers
got super rapey but I think if you were
to rank the performances from the
characters like in terms of like who was
the strongest in the episode who was
maybe not so strong I would say that
Liza is at the top she was definitely
strongest because she had the courage to
know that she needed to die in - Madison
didn't argue with her about it if she
didn't break down and then three Travis
was actually able to do it Daniel still
a strong character but his performance
last week when he was torturing the
soldier that was much more powerful than
he was this week let me know though what
do you think about the characters using
that boat next season we must always
stay in constant motion we can't stay
here I think that just implies that
they're gonna be along the coastline
yeah I mean obviously the show's gonna
be filming in Vancouver so we will see
them walking around on land it'd be
weird to have them only on a boat all
the time there'd be no show oh no it was
a great series it was a bit of a slope
or and I think a lot of the complaints
were that people just wanted it to move
at the same pace and have the same
energy is the main show yeah they're
working up to that
but you can kind of see how they're
trying to differentiate it they don't
want to make two versions of the exact
same show that's why I think they chose
California I mean they said this
specifically they wanted that last shot
on the Pacific so obviously that's
something that you were never gonna see
with the atlanta-based characters and
even now that they're in Washington DC
so here's what's going on with the main
show next week starts with Episode one
remember it's just like it is every
single season it's gonna be 16 episodes
it's gonna be pretty crazy I definitely
think that some of the new characters
are gonna be kind of Shady
so very excited about evil ethan embry
plots really awesome stuff happening
this week shows coming back flash arrow
whole bunch of stuff and next week
season six while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here to
learn all about Robb Stark's will in a
game of Thrones people then ask me all
about Robb Stark's will and you can
click here for all my other Walking Dead
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow